well 36 year old garage worker kochie
selamar appeared in court in person
today
to enter that not guilty plea to the
murder of sabine and nessa he was
wearing a grey t-shirt and a face mask
and he spoke helped by an albanian
interpreter although
although he denies the murder of sabine
nessa what he did do as you say is
accepted that he is the one
responsible for killing her now it's
alleged that mr selamar hit
sabine nessa with a weapon as she walked
home through cater park in kidbrook on
the 17th of september
in on her way to meet a friend and it
was the following day that her body was
found
covered in grass near a community center
in the park and the prosecution alleged
that this was a premeditated
and predatory attack now miss nessa was
28 years old when she died she was a
primary school teacher and after her
death there was a huge outpouring of
grief there was a public vigil attended
by hundreds of people
where her sister spoke and in fact her
family came to court today
for this hearing of course her death was
only a couple of months after the murder
of sarah everard by police officer wayne
cousins which caused a huge amount
of public outrage now at this stage mr
kochi selamar is set for a further
hearing on the 25th of february next
year and his trial for the murder of
sabine nessa is due to begin on the 7th
of june